good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday happy
hump day claudia just reminded me
because she is currently humping someone
she loves hey claude how are you doing
looks like you're changing your sheets
back there i am yes it's wednesday now
that we're doing home episodes you guys
are going to see i'm on a very
consistent wednesday sheet changing
schedule and today it's no different got
to change the sheets i also like have
been through a journey with my sheets
that i actually haven't really spoken
about and like i'm embarrassed to tell
you because like i did something kind of
like really like unhygienic and gross
what did you do okay
so do you remember the brain
unburden yourself claudia yeah yeah okay
and ben is the only one who knows about
it when you do something like
embarrassing it only helps to just like
share it and then it's all of our
problem 100 i will i'm so i'm gonna i'm
gonna just sip on my coffee i'm really
nervous and excited to hear what
what you did with your sheets so one of
our previous and current sponsors is
purple and they make mattresses but they
also make amazing pillows and they sent
us this pillow
like a couple months ago that like
really changed my life like it's just
such a good pillow i've been like my
sleep has never been the same this is
not an ad is it the one that has all the
like nooks and crannies yeah it's like
squishy almost yeah it's amazing it's
amazing and so when it came it came
obviously without a pillow case and i
slept with it for a few days without a
pillowcase and then and it was like
amazing life-changing and then when i
had my sheets changed my housekeeper put
a pillowcase on it like a normal person
and i slept with it on a pillowcase and
i was just like it's not the same like
it's just not the same sleep i think i
need to take the pillowcase off
and i realize it's not like the cleanest
thing to do but i started sleeping with
it without a pillowcase and then like
over time you know like my skin products
my hair products it started to get this
like really good smell that was just
like me in a pillow i know that sounds
disgusting it wasn't gross it was like
it was cute like it was a good smell i
swear
okay
so
like weeks have gone by where i was like
sleeping with smelly pillow that's what
me and men started to call it
and it was like the only thing that i
could sleep with like i swear like i
almost brought it on our vacation like
it's such a part of who i am and then a
couple days ago i was like you know
smelly pillow has taken a turn for the
worse
what do i do i'm like i can throw a
pillowcase on it but the pillow in and
of itself still smells like i gotta
clean it so ben was like throw it in the
wash
the whole pillow right
and i'm like are you sure he was like
yes i swear so we threw it in the wash
and then we threw it in the dryer and
after one tumble in the dryer it wasn't
dry which makes sense so we did a second
one and then a third one and a fourth
and a fifth and it's just like the core
of the pillow was still wet it was in
the dryer the entire day and by the
night time i pulled it out i was like
this is as dry as it's gonna get and so
now smelly pillow is back on the bed
still without a pillow case but has a
different kind of smell like like a
laundry smell okay
and but like not a good laundry smell
like when you leave your clothes in the
washing you forget to put them in the
dryer you know
mold
no i wouldn't say mold just like a
unique interesting smell a sexy unique
smell but most pillowcases come with not
a pillowcase of course but like a
coverlet and i learned this the hard way
because there was a period of time where
brew was enjoying peeing on the pillows
and it wasn't enough to wash the
pillowcases i also saw that they were in
a zippered
thing
[ __ ] that's like a really good call i'm
can you go grab your pillow of course
like we need a smelly pillow hold on i'm
surprised you've lasted this long
without it
we need to get to the bottom of this
because most of the pillows i've
encountered do have a bit of a cover let
on them because sometimes pillows
get stained i can't imagine you missed
this tweeted back oh she needs to put
her headphones in
or does she good news
she has news there's a zipper
are you okay
hold on look smelly pillow right here
oh my god
oh my god it's literally right there
oh my god the inside of the pillow is
not what i thought it would be what is
it
it's just a pillow but like i just
thought it would be like full of
unicorns and like
okay i can't like i
i should wash it
yeah this is a joke i'll handle this
later this is a joke you and that's why
i have to unburden myself to you because
you just know things what the hell is a
pillow cover i don't know but like the
pillow industry knows that things happen
to your pillows and that you need
another barrier you can't just like raw
dog these pillows
[ __ ] so i threw the whole thing in the
wash for no [ __ ] reason for no
[ __ ] reason
great absolutely great news and you
could have been washing you could have
been sleeping the way that you wanted
and washing your pillow at the same time
so wait the good news is that i don't
have to put a case on smelly pillow is
what you're saying right you don't not
if you don't want to ooh
ben will be excited to hear this
i can't believe you guys missed a
[ __ ] zipper that's out in the open i
didn't even know that was a thing like i
thought it was just like a pillow and
then a case
to be fair the first time i experienced
it i didn't know it was a thing either
and then i was like i saw one and i was
like oh my god i need to wash them again
because i can wash the outside do you
think the integrity of the pillow has
been jeopardized i do i think
six cycles in the dryer like that's a
lot of tumbling i think i need to get a
new one i think you do too and i think
that you should because you love it so
much and you learned your lesson
and it won't it won't happen again oh my
god thank you so much you're welcome
that's what i'm here for eternally
indebted to you tips and tricks
well
yesterday was such an interesting day
for me do you know what i did yesterday
well you know but no one else does
because i didn't post about it which was
weird i made a lasagna
oh big mistake i meant to post about it
but then there was no point at which i
was like ready to flex you know and when
it came out i was like it looks like
it's edible i'm not proud of this it's
not like stunning but it was really
delicious
but oh my gosh it was so much work i
assumed the lasagna would be more akin
to like a casserole you just like throw
a bunch of [ __ ] in there and then like
let it bake but you have to
cook each noodle sheet individually
there was like nine of them
yeah lasagna is notoriously laborious oh
my god my back was broken it's not
something you should do
eight months plus pregnant jackie i know
nothing and i could have told you that
i was broken but i ate good for dinner
are you noticing that your lips are
bigger in pregnancy they look so
luscious right now my lips are massive
yeah like they're massive they're
massive they've always been massive
they're extra massive like they have a
little i don't know what percent i would
say they're like five percent bigger
plus i'm wearing you know a bold lip
and i look like a little bit like a
clown no no no you're not giving off any
sort of bozo energy don't worry because
the in the beginning of these um when we
were doing podcasting from home i was
wearing just like a light lip and it
just looked like i wasn't wearing enough
makeup so like amping up the lip color
was a way for me to like look a little
bit
more glam but it has clown vibes no it
doesn't your lips look amazing like what
i would do for those lips
i guess like you know what it makes up
for
not being able to get botox you know a
hundred because obviously if i were
someone who got fillers i wouldn't be
able to get fillers but like
it would even out but i don't know
there's nothing like like my forehead is
out of control
mine's not
it's i'm so jealous i don't
that's been hard one that's been a hard
one to live without it's funny
and surprising what are the things that
i miss the most right okay so postpartum
like i see people on tick tock all the
time like a lot of people like order
subway sandwiches
to um the delivery room because they
can't eat i guess like sweaty meats is
not pregnancy approved not what is like
the two things that you are just dying
to do like some people have a drink i
know that's not what you're looking
forward to no i um and actually watching
vanderpump rules last night which world
recap like made me never like it
watching james and lala sober compared
to how they used to be like it makes me
never want to drink
but anyways things that i'm excited to
do
one skiing i really
like watching people ski this season
like has given me fomo i definitely miss
this season but that's something that
has been hard
two um
what was oh obviously botox what i was
just saying well i was i was worth
saying like things you could do in the
delivery room things i could do
in the hospital
okay things like that i could eat that i
miss
hot dogs oh wow i love how you know
they're like my favorite food so maybe
i'll get some pigs in a blanket
for you um i i miss sushi a little bit
sometimes like some sushi but i also
could eat sushi if i really wanted like
that's what a lot of doctors do say i
mean of course everything is like you
know in moderation and with caution but
if it's a good
piece of fish raw fish like it really
shouldn't
have
any adverse effects so like if i wanted
to i could have some
sushi but whenever i'm craving sushi i
just get an avocado roll or cucumber
roll with soy sauce ginger it does the
trick pretty much but then i look over
at zach's he gets like sugar fish
salmon on that rice by the way like i
totally understand and if you are
craving sushi stay far away from ben's
offer oh yeah no sometimes his stories
i'm like damn yeah but jen has a rabbit
ben has a way of like making the worst
food look good that's like his talent
and even though i've had tuna fish two
times like i do
i do want more tuna fish got it okay
yeah so those are the things but so far
like living without them is not the
biggest deal i miss more so just like
being up like a spray tan
of course i'm getting one today you can
i could get a spray tan like if i
absolutely i don't leave the house so
why would i get one just to stain my
sheets
but like stuff like that um that i've
forsaken but i don't need to but like i
just look forward to like when i can be
a person who has my eyelashes dyed
eyebrows dyed spray tan
nails done
everything you know i got you i just
don't need those things right now which
is why i'm not
even thinking about doing them i never
have mm-hmm
um so of course we have a great show for
you guys today we're going to recap
vanderpump rules but i did want to tell
everyone that i did finish the season
premiere of euphoria and it was really
good like really really good one of my
favorite characters cassie who was
played by sydney sweeney who's like this
hbo star like she's on her way to
becoming
huge people are obsessed she's so unique
looking like she's such a unique shaped
eye and she's a really talented actress
and this episode was very much like her
moment she had like the scene in the
bathroom with jacob belordy where she
her acting was on [ __ ] point like
i've never seen anything like it before
she was
beautiful successful amazing talented
blender put it in a blender give birth
to it throw it up so good there were
some traumatizing moments of the episode
like i don't know why they really had to
show us like a man [ __ ] on the
toilet like from from like a direct
eyeline pov like you saw his penis like
it was so
it was so unnecessary and borderline
traumatizing
that's disgusting no it was so
unnecessary like she's supposed to be
hiding in the bathroom and she's trying
to like wait for the bathroom to empty
so she's hiding behind the shower so she
can run out so nobody saw i won't spoil
like what she was doing in the bathroom
before okay so finally this couple
leaves and she's about to get out and
this guy comes in so she gets back in
the shower and
she like looks out to see what's going
on it's like some guy taking it dump
like it's just so unnecessary that is so
unnecessary yeah it's really annoying
but another thing is like i've been
watching um
all all the casts especially jacob lordy
is doing press and i've been reminded
that jacob lordy is australian which is
just really shocking because he just
doesn't give me like that vibe
yeah
so he really does an amazing american
accent
good for him i guess in all of his films
the kissing booth critically acclaimed
oscar winning film
what else has he been in
the kissing booth won oh he was in the
kissing with two
oh and the kissing booth three okay is
that really it that is some other stuff
but i don't think i've seen it okay so
it's not like popping no he's very like
artsy if you look at his instagram he's
really into photography i think he does
like a bunch of like student films not
student films like indies
that's that's nice for him yeah but he's
really on his way to being like
brad pitt of our generation
that's that's nice for him yeah everyone
in the cast like this show is so big and
it's so good for them they're all just
like becoming it reminds me of how the
kids from riverdale became like that
show was a part like such a huge part of
like the cultural zeitgeist and then
immediately they had like millions and
millions of followers millions and
millions of fans that's what it reminds
me of but for like a more mature
audience for a more mature art audience
to say the least yeah um
so that's what i did and then i just had
the busiest day yesterday because
scheduling announcement i'm going to
mexico tomorrow so tomorrow's episode
will be podcast only and then we're off
friday and monday for martin luther king
weekend hope everyone has a nice long
weekend then we're back doing the
integrated interface on tuesday
exciting we hope you have a great time
thank you for seeing your face but it'll
be so worth it for you to get some good
times good vibes under your belt and to
come back to us you know renewed come
back with stories to tell a tan face
like no one has to look at this big ass
michelin man for much longer it's gonna
be great for all of us like we're all
gonna benefit i i look forward to it i
really really do
um there's like not that much going on
in the world today except for obviously
jamie lynn on gma this morning is huge
yeah there's actually some interesting
stuff some not so interesting stuff
there's a story about drake that i'm so
excited to share with you uh you haven't
heard it yet and i'm looking forward to
getting your two cents it's kind of um
unverified but just the rumor itself is
so worth discussing you know like
nothing grinds my gears more than an
unverified source
yeah no it's it's very um rumor mill but
it's worth discussing and we're gonna
we're gonna talk about it so without
further a do
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
modern fertility the traditional
guidance with fertility has been just
wait and see but now we have tools to
help us plan and track for everything in
our lives wellness finance career school
and so why is fertility still a wait and
see knowledge is power and that's why
modern fertility was created it's an
easy and affordable way to test your
fertility hormones at home with a simple
finger prick mail it in with a prepaid
label and you'll get your personalized
results within 10 days you'll get
insight into your hormone levels your
ovarian reserve aka how many eggs you
have
compared to other women your age you
also get other important fertility
factors and the results go super deep
into what every hormone means and you
can also talk one on one with a
fertility nurse to review your results
and options for next steps so
traditional testing when you go to a
doctor is super expensive it can cost
over a thousand dollars but the modern
fertility service gets you the same
information at just 159
which is a fraction of the price and if
you go to modernfertility.com
toast you'll get 20 off your test so
again that's 159
minus our 20
code at modernfertility.com
toast so if you want kids one day maybe
in the future
or you just want to be want clinically
sound information about your body modern
fertility is here for you and they are
offering our listeners 20 off the test
when you go to modern fertility.com
toast and that means your test will cost
139
instead of the hundreds or thousands it
could cost you at a doctor's office get
20 off your fertility test when you go
to modernfertility.com
toast
modernfertility.com
toast
great thank you claudia
it's pleasure
our first story jamie lynn spears is
sitting down with gma and saying quote i
went out of my way to help brittany end
the conservatorship jamie lynn spears
claimed in a rare tv interview wednesday
that she tried to help her now estranged
sister britney spears
controversial conservatorship
she said i've always been my sister's
biggest supporter so when she needed
help i set up ways to do so i went out
of my way to make sure that she had the
contacts she needed to possibly go ahead
and end this conservatorship and just
end this all for our family if it's
going to cause this much discord why
continue it
she did not reveal which contacts she
gave britney nor whether the pop star
ever got in touch with them
i hate to see sisters feuding especially
in the public eye it just gives me a pit
it's just not good
but at the end of the day two sisters
are saying two totally different things
and i'm inclined to believe britney
because to me brittany's a victim in all
this she doesn't really have much to
gain by lying on the other hand jamie
has quite a lot to gain by lying the
public has really turned against jamie
she has this big book coming out that's
what gma was for to promote the book so
she's like fighting this uphill battle
and i feel like she's saying anything
to win whereas like britney has nothing
left to lose like she has literally lost
her freedom like she has no reason to
lie i'm gonna back britney but i just
want to say i hate seeing
sisterhood divided i agree and also over
the last 13 years while britney was in
her conservatorship i'm sure she would
have done anything for an ally
especially someone in her family and
someone who could like vouch for her and
help her out and so i think if jamie
lynn was that person britney wouldn't
have forgotten that no and there's a
paper trail there is physical evidence
that jamie lynn was benefiting
financially from the conservatorship
like i really don't feel like the gma
woman has the right answers i mean the
right questions
yeah it's tough to
to speculate and you don't know and even
like you know so much of this is public
but really not so it's really what she
said versus what she said and i just
think that britney if her sister had had
her back in a real way
she would remember like she's looking
for allies friends family like she's
wanted support all this time if she had
support she wouldn't have just thrown it
by the wayside no and it's easy to
support her now like when she's free and
the whole world is rooting for her like
that's easy but in the hard times when
britney was labeled like crazy and she
had no access to her money and she was
being like forced to go on different
drugs like where was the ally ship then
yeah
agreed and by the way i do want to say
what jamie said in the interview which i
do agree with like when this whole thing
started i don't think jamie lynn has
been like you know uh plotting since the
beginning when britney was put into a
conservatorship jamie lynn was 17 and
she was pregnant like i do believe
at first she had nothing to do with it
she had her own problems her own life
going on i believe she lived in
louisiana i don't think that she's this
whole time been like a conspirator
but you get old you get responsibilities
it's your sister you have to have her
back it's your family it's on you to do
the right thing and she didn't so that i
do blame her for right and also the
reasons for the conservatorship
13 years ago like after 13 like things
change and things are in flux for 13
years so even if at the time you had
nothing to do with it and maybe at the
time it sounded like a good idea based
on things that were happening like
britney has been struggling for her
freedom for a few years now and at any
point you could have stepped up and
helped her out
or been like a voice for in the way that
like her boyfriend
fiance are they engaged i can't remember
um
sam like for like the last year has
really been like her mouthpiece like she
can't even couldn't even control her own
instagram so he would respond to like
certain things in in a way that he in
the best way that he could given the
fact that they were literally like in a
prison so jamie could have been that too
but she wasn't
yeah but she brittany needed jamie and
jamie was nowhere to be found and those
scars don't heal overnight
yeah i agree i i don't know where we go
from here with the two of them it is sad
to see
them feuding
and also jamie lynn's got to sell books
so right so always keep that in mind
no but it's like so she needs to do
press to sell her books like and the
press is going to ask about brittany
because that's really the biggest story
in the world and also the biggest story
in jamie's life so she's going to be
talking about it ergo we're going to be
hearing about the feud even if
perhaps she doesn't want to be talking
about it can i tell you something i feel
like this book
so it takes a really long time to write
and publish a book like one and a half
to two years maybe one to two years
so i have a feeling when the concept for
this book was being conceptualized and
being written and being published the
thought of the conservatorship ever
actually ending was so far-fetched that
i think jamie thought she could release
this book due press on
unresponded by britney if that makes
sense and then once the conservatorship
was
cancelled it was like about the same
time that the book announcement was
scheduled like the train was already
moving you can't stop the books have
been published they've been printed
they've been sent to bookstores you
can't stop it so i think now like
hindsight if she could not do the book
she wouldn't have done the book
but
the timing was like so not in jamie
lynn's favor like she thought she could
just say whatever she wanted and no one
would be there to check her
yeah that's true
that's what i think i mean but i would
have to read the book to make that call
yes because she does talk about the
conservatorship in the book
does she
so sh okay so i was under the impression
that she didn't because like i said this
book must have been written two years
ago
and in the interview she said well i
wrote in the book about the
conservatorship how i said x y and z
um and i found that shocking
i'm sure that she mentions it but the
book is not about that like it's about
her
journey i'm so like her i would have to
read the book
i would have to read the book to
decipher what her intentions were when
she made the decision to publish it and
how much her plans have been derailed
are you going to read the book
um i don't think so
but you never know i i mean if i if it
comes highly recommended then maybe i
would like if i heard really good things
about it but uh i'm not i don't know i
haven't read a celeb memoir in a while i
have got a lot that i'm actually looking
to read um like some fiction books and
also some
uh what is the category if it's like not
self-help advice how like parenting
stuff so
yeah i don't think this book is going to
come highly recommended in my opinion
we'll see let us know if you guys have
read it please let me know i don't think
it's out yet
well maybe you got a netgalley preview
right right right
okay our next story crazy news j drake
jake
drake from state farm
drake seemingly responds to rumors of
putting hot sauce in a condom to prevent
a woman stealing his sperm i did hear
this
okay
so drake has posted an instagram caption
that maybe makes it seem like he's
responding to this crazy story which i
will give you the details this is from
too much hot tea on instagram
allegedly an instagram model is trying
to sue drake for putting hot sauce in
his condom
allegedly drake and the instagram model
allegedly met up on instagram and the
two decided to link up a few weeks ago
the model in drake had a romantic
encounter and what happened next was
crazy so the two of them had sex
then
he
he wore a condom for the sexual
encounter
and he went to the um bathroom after to
dispose of it
the girl fished the condom out of the
trash untied it and put the opening into
her vagina boy was she in for a surprise
she said it felt like pouring hot lava
into her [ __ ]
she screamed and drake ran into the
bathroom he admitted that he poured
hot sauce in
this is the caption on too much hot tea
i said [ __ ] i said you said [ __ ] i
said it okay yep hot lava and the [ __ ]
she screamed and drake ran into the
bathroom he admitted that he poured a
packet of hot sauce in the condom to
kill the sperm now the instagram model
is threatening to sue drake
oh my god what [ __ ] nerve
what [ __ ] nerve i mean first of all a
lot of people are saying like this can't
be true why wouldn't he just like flush
the condom down the toilet there are
other ways to get rid of a condom and
make sure like someone's not trying to
like only illegally inseminate
themselves without your consent uh but
perhaps
it is true
like by the way this sounds i don't know
100 believable
i kind of agree and you know what i kind
of hope that it's true like obviously i
like r.i.p to her vagina but what are
you doing
what do you think like this is your like
you just found a career you're gonna
steal some sperm and get pregnant like
i honest if drake really does this with
his condoms i have so much respect me
too how unethical to like go fish out a
condom to try and trick someone of a
certain status wealth fame into
fatherhood like that is so
[ __ ] up and what's even more [ __ ] up
is this [ __ ]
thinking
she can sue
i i don't know the legalities but i have
to imagine that trying to like steal
someone's sperm
is illegal in some way i could argue
drake could sue her
right right so like if i'm her and i
just got caught trying to steal your
sperm and like really make a moment for
myself um i'm just gonna take the l
and
move on you know it didn't work out your
big plan was foiled
yeah and you know what like it's so
it's so upsetting that like
obviously you know drake has millions of
dollars like he's a very privileged
person but that must be extremely
difficult
to especially when you're a single guy
and like so much of your lifestyle being
a celebrity is like meeting girls having
sex with them it's like one of the perks
you know
but this is something you always have to
look out for and honestly like just in
my opinion like get a girlfriend like
you could have sex with her as much as
you want someone you could trust and
they're not gonna put a sperm-filled
condom up their [ __ ]
no i was thinking the same thing like
how empty is it to have even have like
sex with someone and she talked about
the sex like that it was very consensual
and like they were both really into it
but to even have sex with like good sex
with someone and you just really can't
[ __ ] trust them like
i mean i'm sure in the beginning like
it's all very exciting but he's been a
big star for a very long time now and i
and i
imagine it really wears on you you know
every time after you finish the act like
you have to go pour hot sauce in the
condom because like you just can't trust
anybody so yeah it's like get a
girlfriend but then it's like eventually
that girlfriend might want kids too
okay but you know what you've been with
someone for three years then you can
have a baby with them in a consensual
manner i just like i can't imagine that
this lifestyle of like hooking up with a
million girls is worth it when like
these are the consequences these are the
way people treat you like and you know
what makes me sad there are so many
girls that i know who are lovely
delicious nice girls
who would do
anything to have sex with drake not have
a baby with him just one night with
drake you know and the girls that
actually get to the one night with drake
are disgusting girls
yeah
yeah and also it makes you like think
about the fact like i feel like so often
we hear about
celebrities who are you know getting
women pregnant and not meaning to
just are like why don't you wear a
condom like
safe sex and it's like
maybe they are
no maybe they are
and the girls are shoving it up their
[ __ ] no that's an amazing amazing call
and do we know like who this girl is or
it's still all just like an alleged
story does she have a name it's all an
alleged story she's instagram model and
the only
small verification is that um
drake posted to his instagram like a
nice photo of himself and he said you
can have your 15 minutes of fame i'll
have the other 23 hours and 45 minutes
okay that's like really not like um
any sort of validation for me it could
be like a new lyric in his next song
okay but no no i mean is anything ever
validation like we just never we just
sit here and like try and put pieces of
a puzzle together we just sit here and
stew
yeah but overall when i read this story
i was just like
good for drake
yeah no when i read this story i was
like what a sad
like life to live
people want you for your sperm not
because they think you're so great and
want to have your children because they
want money from you and imagine like
bringing a child into the world in that
way spite baby
beyond no but at least there was like a
relationship
no and there was like a consent to have
a child
right both people knew that
child making could happen right no this
is so [ __ ] up it makes me think so
like little of humanity
yeah
and you know what
it's literally like a cautionary tale do
evil things evil will be done unto your
[ __ ]
yeah and also i think this is whether or
not this is true like it's just a good
thing to have floating out there like i
don't know maybe don't pour the condom
in your [ __ ] could have hot sauce in it
no the next girl who's inspired to do
this will have heard the story and like
maybe she'll hesitate when reaching into
the trash for the cum-filled condom to
be like what if there's hot sauce in
here you know is that a risk i'm
personally willing to take it'll make
them take take a step back and think
yeah so i don't know sometimes a lesson
can be learned from everything i'm just
sad like i really want drake to find and
you know in my in my heart of hearts
he's a nice jewish boy like we would
find him in like we need to stand up
with snatcher snatcher would never do
that
censor would never do that i agree and
also i'm sure like out of all the crazy
things like drake and so many other
celebs like have seen like this is
really not even
a thing like you know obviously you hear
about people like poking holes in
condoms but like you can check for that
you can know if that happened um
i just i'm i feel like this is a whole
like
set of things to worry about that i i
never even thought about
no totally like it's this is an
eye-opening story for me
i completely agree
anyways
very interesting nonetheless
but sending our best regards best wishes
to drake
yes
are you ready for our next story there
was one more thing i wanted to say
because you remember how yesterday i was
talking i'm like learning so much about
euphoria i'm like two years behind um
you know i was saying yesterday how like
the music on euphoria is becoming like
the new trl mm-hmm and it was like what
came first the song on take talk or the
song on euphoria somebody let me know
that drake is actually a producer on
euphoria
and that really speaks to why the music
is so you know
on point oh that's so cool
very cool
our next story kim kardashian and pete
davidson hit the outlet mall for caramel
apples and frozen bananas
kim and pete indulged in their sweet
tooths in california on monday hitting
the camarillo premium outlets mall
seaming bodyguards in tow for a sugar
fix they stopped into the rocky mountain
chocolate factory to get caramel apples
and frozen bananas like she always does
when she's out there a photo of the
couple was spotted on jumois and was
later picked up by nori's black book um
i love how these are becoming like valid
news sources
facebook.com
despite other reports they did not hit
any of the other star stores in the mall
i just want to say like so so kim like
remember that episode where she hid in
the back of the rolls royce so that
jonathan would go get her a wetzel's
pretzel
yeah this is so yeah we're like just
really being herself
yeah no and she like has her sweet tooth
and i feel like kim like knows what's
good especially when it comes to food
like her and her beignets and i feel
like she like works really hard she like
tears it up in the gym and then she also
treats herself but she like knows the
exact things to get so i want to go to
the rocky mountain chocolate shop with
kim kardashian no like i want to travel
and you have to think about it it's been
like what 15 years that kim has been
famous she's traveled all around the
world eaten at the best restaurants and
she knows like the best of the best
whether that's michelin star or it's in
an outlet mall like i want to go on a
global food tour with kim like she knows
how to eat
she needs to collab with zagats
and give us a guide that's the best food
out there yeah i mean i don't know it's
like when you're collabing with fendi do
you then go to zagats
but that's kim she's like america's
celeb
get you a girl who can do both the zagat
x fendi
gat x skims
something yeah they can make really cute
fanny packs for traveling
suitcases cute
no i'm telling you anyways these two are
like really going strong i know i say
this every single time we report about
them doing anything because but like
they are in like a s real ass
relationship they're seeing each other
like every day and they're working hard
stepping out he's like truly new york
based and she's truly la based so you
know they're working hard earning those
credit card miles and they're putting in
the effort
yeah obviously like it's on him to get
out to see her more one because like his
show's not in season and two like she's
got four kids and she's a lawyer and
she's this and that and obviously um but
they're making me come to you they're
spending time
they're spending a lot of time together
and like
when you spend that much time with
someone you really have to like them
otherwise you're being tortured
and you know pete is like known for
being spotted with beautiful women and
it doesn't always it's aside from ariana
grande and maybe phoebe denver like it
doesn't last
past like two or three appearances so
now kim and pete have been spotted like
six times
yeah this makes me feel crazy it never
it never ceases i know i'm a broken
record but like every time they do
something new i'm just like
i'm in shock again
but i just do want to say that in my
personal like my vision board for kim's
life i don't have her ending up with
pete like this is a fun
single gal adventure
but what i see for kim is much bigger
but this is great for her pr i'm sure
she's having so much fun i love it short
term agreed agreed short term even i'll
take up to a year
yeah this is just not how it ends for
kim
no no no oh no
she looks like someone on her level
yeah agreed our next story
some
i guess exciting news not at all just
trying to be positive the oscars this
year will have a host for the first time
since 2018.
literally nobody asked for
after a long streak of going without a
host the oscars will once again have an
emcee for the first time since 2018 the
awards show will will be led by a yet to
be named host the telecast is set to air
on march 27th on abc
so
my question to you is who do you think
should host the oscars the rumors are
that it's tom hiddleston
i didn't see that taylor swift's
ex-boyfriend
yeah no i know i'm familiar with him
low-key loki
yeah
i haven't seen that i've really been
trying to think of who it could be now
since it's on abc it's not going to be
kelly clarkson because she is an nbc
girly that's a really good call
so you have to think about abc talent
i don't think it's going to be one of
the late night hosts i think that they
they're not very self-aware but i think
they know enough to know that nobody
wants to hear from them at the oscars to
be honest like i'm really not interested
in watching a hosted oscars until kevin
hart
gets what is rightfully his
yeah and i feel like if he wanted to do
it they would let him do it but he's so
done with the academy after like that
whole drama
but to be honest he would be incredible
at it
and
it's time like it is time if he wanted
to do it they would have him do it he
does not want to do it anymore i mean
who really would want to do it so but
there are people obviously if you're at
the top of your game like you only have
what to lose by hosting the oscars but
there are people who would stand to gain
something maybe someone on the c list
you know but someone who's really
talented who could if someone could step
up to the plate and do an amazing job
which isn't that far-fetched it's just
doing
good at your job being funny people
liking you like it would be a major
opportunity for them i have to believe
that there's someone out there who is
willing to take that on
no you're right it's really a thankless
job and
when i think of like anne hathaway who
was you know bella the ball of the
oscars year after year and then hosted
she was annihilated like you're right
someone who's at the top of their game
it's a job that like literally no matter
how good you do people will say they
hated it
it's always 50 50. so like who would
want to [ __ ] do that when you could
just go to the awards and like win and
like hang out with people and party and
drink or you have to stand on stage and
like do the hardest job ever so
you're right like a c-lister who will
love the recognition even if they don't
do a great job like it's still the
biggest gig they'll ever have
i don't know let's just talk about the
possibility of it being tom hiddleston
i'm not super familiar with his
personality i think he is really well
liked i just think the choice is like so
uninspired i think that would be a train
wreck honestly
like really i mean i don't know him um
on a personal level or even on like i i
know you at all i've never seen him in
anything or like watch an interview with
him but i can't imagine he's like the
funniest
person and i think a lot of people would
be like who is this guy no i think we
need like a mid-tier comedian
honestly
like pete davidson
oh my god
even though he's not mid-tier he's
higher than that and he's on snl and
that's nbc and he's probably too big for
what we're saying but like someone who
you know has a comedy special that's on
a streaming service right now that could
use a couple million views more like
could use that bump and someone who's
genuinely funny that would do a good job
yeah no you're right pete davidson gives
me like a similar vibe to ricky gervais
which in my opinion was like the most
recent great host he's amazing who just
didn't give a [ __ ] but yes also like
maybe a comedy duo like michael che and
colin jost are really good together
live they go on tour together live
they're
experienced
i don't know i don't think people want
to hear it from them
why people love them no i i think
they're too like
they're just too established almost and
it feels like more of the same
yeah
so honestly like
bo burnham
yeah like someone
someone who's just gonna like get out
there like a podcaster really yeah
that's what i'm i'm thinking of like the
comedian x podcaster community tim
dillon tim dillon
you
would you do it
a hundred percent [ __ ] kidding me
will you
i don't know host the oscars
okay fine well i mean not this year
because i'm like i wouldn't want to be i
wouldn't want to be seen on tv like you
know
like this no botox but um
in the like hypothetically yeah i guess
who said the [ __ ] says no to that right
even though i'd be ripped to shreds
yeah you're right like uh
because for me and i know it was like a
controversial
you know night but when ricky's your
vase did it it was so out there and he
was just saying the things so many
people were thinking like it was the
midst of the metoo movement and it was
just all so hypocritical and he just
went there like in front of the people
who are being like the hypocrites
and it was really good i think like
america loved it at least i did
yeah i think they should look towards
the podcast comedy charts
yeah like bill burr
and make oh that's who i thought you
were talking about when you said beau
burnham
no bo burnham is inside yeah he's the
the singer in his room and he by the way
he is very musically inclined like he
could do
musical bits i think it would be good i
think that's actually a really good i
didn't watch inside
but people loved it and i actually think
that that's like the perfect choice me
too especially because like he's really
famous in a niche
niche comedy community especially like a
it's like a really specific corner of
the internet but this would be like his
big public break
okay i think that we we've given them
some really good thought starters
and it can be done like tom hiddleston
is the right choice no no no but i just
want to say like it can be done like
there is a path to success here like
there
it doesn't have to go like it doesn't
have to be the golden globes 2022 where
we're just on our way to not even
televised like we can turn this thing
around you guys and i can't believe i'm
saying this like i'm trying to be
optimistic about the oscars but like
yeah it's just i hate to see the failure
the abject failure and i do think tom
hiddleston would just he would be like
another jimmy kimmel even though he's
not like a late night host he's just
like i'm sure he's a lovely person this
is nothing against him he's just like
bleh and he he like he's the type of
person who will be at the oscars one day
so it's like he's just one of them like
you need an outsider a hundred percent
a hundred percent
okay so we've given you a lot to think
about let us know who you think should
host the oscars yes i would love to hear
other people's um choices
and our fifth and final story is that
summer house star lindsey hubbard
finally confirms that she's dating carl
radke oh
slow news day yeah
but a lot of people are like shook up
about this okay in an interview with
page six she finally confirmed her
relationship with summerhouse's carl she
said we're definitely dating
um before adding that they haven't
assumed the boyfriend girlfriend label
just yet oh that's a little awkward
yeah i mean i imagine it's difficult
when you're dating someone and you have
to deal with like the regular dating
stuff like are we taking your
relationship yeah are we seeing other
people like there's all these different
obstacles before you get to like
boyfriend and girlfriend and it's really
awkward and then having like the whole
public element where people are wanting
you to confirm it but it's like this guy
hasn't even confirmed it like right
there's a lot like i actually i have a
lot of sympathy that must be incredibly
awkward right and everyone thinks you're
just like being quaint and annoying and
it's like no we haven't had the talk yet
can you pipe down can you shut the [ __ ]
up yeah right and everyone like is
probably like influencing or she or if
it were me like i would feel like a
people's comments would be influencing
like how he's feeling about the
relationship and it's like so much
pressure and everything is coming hard
enough as it is
without
all of that so i agree with you that
that must be trying and like she said we
don't really talk in labels carl and i
but we're very much together and we're
very happy and it's like
having that like labels discussion even
as a as a regular person is so
uncomfortable now you have to tell page
six like we don't talk about labels
right now it's just like an added
element of uncomfort to an already
uncomfortable situation like defining
your relationship with a guy especially
if he's like a previous like he's like a
recovering [ __ ] boy it's just like it's
awkward
yeah it's awkward so i'm glad that
they're figuring it out i feel like it's
been a really long time we reported on
this a while ago that they were like
seen together and
perhaps dating it's been like a while
since then though so
i would think that's so confusing like
because i watched i didn't even finish
winter house but like when i was on
winter house like she was in love with
austin and perhaps pursuing something
with someone else like
and i don't i don't think i'm gonna
watch summer house but i don't think
that their relationship
was even like a thing then so it's just
very confusing when you're on a reality
tv show and it's airing of [ __ ] that
happened a year ago yeah well speaking
of that could lead into our tv recap yes
vanderpump rules was on last night we've
got lots to say and vanderpump rules
recap is brought to you by paint your
life if you want to give your wife
husband grandmother parents the perfect
gift this year
then you gotta check out
paintyourlife.com
where you can get a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo at a really affordable price so
you choose from a team of world-class
artists and you work with them until
every detail is perfect their platform
is super user friendly it lets you order
a custom made hand-painted portrait in
less than five minutes it's a really
quick and easy process and the whole
thing can take about like three weeks so
you send a picture of you yourself your
children your family a pet which is
exactly what i did or you can combine
multiple photos into a painting it makes
the perfect birthday gift anniversary
wedding anything i got one made of theo
for ben for our anniversary it is
literally my most prized possession
because it was a gift for ben but really
a gift for me totally i got one of my
wedding photos made into it and it just
looks like an actual work of art this is
the best gift it's obviously thoughtful
but it's sickening and it's literally
art in your house and you are you're the
muse it's also a great way to
commemorate someone who's passed away
like i know a lot of people take like
their wedding photos where maybe their
grandfather wasn't there and they have a
picture of their grandfather put it's
just really cool you can get really
creative with your own thing or just
recreate a photo it's the best
best gift and at paintyourlife.com
there's no risk if you don't love the
final painting your money's refunded
guaranteed and right now is a limited
time offer get 20 off your painting 20
off and free shipping to get the special
offer text morning to sixty four
thousand so it's morning as in the
morning toast text morning to sixty four
thousand
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most terms available at
paintyourlife.com terms again that's
text morning to 64 000.
great
so vanderpump rules was actually pretty
good i thought um actually it's kind of
sad like seeing all this like engagement
stuff because i thought the weekend was
really beautiful and really well done
and it was clear that like they paid a
lot of money and raquel put like a lot
of thought into the weekend it was just
beautiful and now knowing that they're
not even engaged anymore it's like sad
agreed it was so stunning and the more
beautiful it was and with every room
that we saw and everything that they
planned the more
the brock meter went down like
oh
well let's talk about the engagement i
wish i could have had like a camera on
my face while i was watching rock scenes
in this episode like i was
i can't even find the words to explain
how i feel
every week i and i was like gonna call
you to like just commiserate about it
but like every week i am more and more
upset
by what i see from brock on the show
okay but let's just let's take it to the
engagement so he thought he went from
literally like a rooftop hollywood
premiere shotgun wedding
to literally like some dingy hotel
after
they signed their prenup
and
just that's their apartment
i think oh my god that's worse
yeah no i think it was there they were
going home
it looks like a hotel key i don't know
why i think it was like a it's a new
high-tech apartment building interesting
okay and that's why like the mom was
there and the baby was there she was
just about to walk into her apartment he
was like wait wait so that's even worse
he didn't even pay for a hotel room he
paid for literally a balloon arch from
party city right and when the cars were
honking in the background i was like is
this an episode of the morning
jackie that's literally one of my pet
[ __ ] peeps like when i go i know it's
like so obnoxious but like i'm always
aware of the sounds like when i was
touring venues for my wedding i was like
nope i just heard a honk absolutely not
during my wedding ceremony i heard like
a fork drop because like they were like
setting up in a different room for like
cocktail hour i was like oh my god my
wedding's ruined like i'm so triggered
by sounds and that was really i don't
know if that was super imposed
i don't think so it sounded like it
didn't seem dirty
but i just need to hype up to anything i
don't even know that this was the
episode she was getting engaged in play
music they didn't even make it seem cute
they had horns they did her [ __ ]
dirty i just want to say they could have
edited in a way where it would still be
bad but we wouldn't be like bashing it
so hard i just want to say like
something nice about sheena because like
sheena is just such a sport you know and
like she and of course like to default
to a fault definitely like and she has
to learn everything the hard way and
it's infuriating but
she really is like so hopeful and when
it comes to love like she she really is
blind like no she's a hopeless romantic
she's a worse way and it's like she
really doesn't get bogged down by you
know the fact that this is my engagement
or you know our wedding is gonna be like
on someone else's dime on someone else's
day like and yes she should like i mean
i i wish that she eventually was like no
we shouldn't do it then but like it's
like she doesn't even need all this
stuff like she just wants the love and
the relationship and i i respect that a
lot and like even when brock is just
like being embarrassing like she really
has his back so like as a partner like
sheena really is a queen
agreed
but then there's all the other stuff
no and like at at some point like she's
a woman a mature woman a mother
there is a responsibility on sheena to
stop a train wreck when she sees it and
it's one that she's involved in and when
they went to her with the idea and she
loved it i was so disappointed in her
and then even when she got there and
sandoval like expressed his concern and
she keeps saying if nobody finds out
it's gonna be fine but the possibility
of nobody finding out is a hundred
percent impossible they're on a [ __ ]
reality tv show right now he's just
really making me
annoyed he said we just need to keep it
super super secret for a while and like
so that no one ever thought that we took
away from them but
and then eventually like people will
know and they won't care because like
they didn't know that it happened so i
think like he obviously knew that it's
going to be on a tv show we're going to
find out but it's like even you having
this conversation at the wine tasting is
taking away from james
and raquel no and you know what they're
so [ __ ] dramatic because like if they
had just showed up and sheena wore her
ring no one would be mad you're allowed
to get engaged like it's not a big deal
but they're so dramatic and like
secretive like we can't tell anyone we
got engaged but we can get married the
weekend of raquel and james is like
they're so like unwell
they are so unwell i was
i was in shock i was cringing like
i went into this like just watching
sheena's relationship over the last two
years like before the show aired and
then you know i went into this season
like being like wow sheena like has love
like she has this family and i was ready
to like just tote like support you know
if he just was even like semi
a good guy
and just every week it's red red red red
flag after another and i'm just in shock
no and like if you go on sheena's social
media like she's just people have a lot
of questions and people especially in
the vanderpump rules like fandom are
really mean and so they're asking like
these really rude questions and sheena's
just responding to every single one of
them like just defending her ring
defending her man defending her
decisions her choices and it just makes
me so sad like this is supposed to be
like a happy time in your life but they
just went about it in the most moronic
stupid way that it's like no one's i'm
not even thinking like oh how nice for
china she found love i'm like what the
hell is going on yeah no and sheena
deserves better because she is so
[ __ ] ride or die like and she really
doesn't complain
no matter how embarrassing her man is
being or how little she is getting in
regards to like what she deserves which
is respect which is a respect which is a
proper wedding with where your friends
can be there and even know about it and
even know you were engaged like she's
that's something that she loves she's
pregnant like like they have something
to hide what the [ __ ] is the rush
both of their second marriages like you
already have a kid
like yeah the secret's out well then the
rush and the secrets okay some people
have said
you know it's they wanted it on the show
so that it could be paid for that's what
i was thinking that too but what's there
to pay for there's three people there
um it's giving green card
vibes yeah we didn't talk about that
last week but they did speak about his
um visa status
um and as just like an added benefit of
being in love and having a child is you
know oh what a great time like i happen
to be getting kicked out of the country
and i happen to be engaged it's it's
cause for concern
yeah i do think they would get married
anyway so like if you're gonna have to
go like leave the country we should do
it sooner than later but like tell
everyone bring us down to the courthouse
bring the cameras and get married like
oh my god if you leave it's much harder
to come back even with a fiancee so i
get it no but so say like they're
they're really in a rush for a green
card but like they're also in a
relationship a real relationship they
have a family and they're going to get
married anyway okay but we need to speed
it up like but still why does it have to
be so secret and like
tacky and gucci like when we could do
something so cute at the courthouse like
and just straight up we didn't even talk
about the photo shoot which was the
nicest photo shoot i've literally ever
seen on tv i've ever seen in real life
it was so and you know i'm so glad la la
and katie talked about it because it's
like
this is he kept talking about was
startup has no money started has no
money started has no money which i
totally get but either you're lying
about how much money the startup has or
you are misappropriating funds to the
nth degree there was literally no reason
why that studio needed to be that nice
that many models why do you need a dj
for a photo shoot plug in your ipad no
100 also he said he was setting up for
days which means like you were renting
that space for days usually like you get
it for a few hours so like for i don't
know 72 hours like how much did that
cost also
i'll say something nice before i go in
one for an at-home fitness company i
think the name homebody is perfection
agreed
what is the company are we is it apparel
is it like no it's workouts i think it's
like beachbody yeah it's like um a
streaming service for yeah okay so then
what the [ __ ] did we watch last night we
watched a photo shoot for um an
athleisure company that's what yeah
that's what we watched and also then
like people were doing squats and stuff
but like these aren't trainers so like
why is this really is this what you're
streaming on your platform like
he had a major opportunity to show us
his business you know and i don't know
what the business is and
he he lost like wha
i i i don't unders
i do believe it's at home workouts like
you know like the peloton app no 100
but then what was the photo shoot why is
what is lala doing she's not a trainer
what is any of them doing they're just
like wearing clothes that say homebody
and taking pictures what is this for no
no i don't know and so if it wasn't like
if he spent all that money to and he had
a major hour promo
no but if he had all these hours in the
studio and like we were filming
hours of content for the site
okay that's yes that's the cost of the
app but like this is all marketing and
promotion budget that was the vibe that
i got marketing you're out of control
i do want to say one thing about china a
positive because you know she's getting
so swept up she's letting brock like
really make her look bad and to make all
these bad decisions but i just love
how she and it's a little tacky to do it
on tv and it's like uncomfortable but
her standing her ground so
wholeheartedly with the prenup making
sure like she's like my retirement i
want everything of mine and i want seven
percent of yours like yes girl get your
coin because not only did she have to
learn the hard way the first time
this guy is possible is even worse off
financially than shay mooney oh no
that's the guy from dan and chai
mike shay mike shay
yeah i agree but again it's like it's
like this sheena extreme where it's like
if that hadn't happened
if she literally like she has to just
learn everything the hard way and it's
and it's and everything in hindsight and
it's just that painful like having to
watch her go through because if that
hadn't happened she would never she
would she would say whatever she said
probably about shay which is like you
know well we're in love and we're going
to be together forever like it's like
it's just it's hard to watch sometimes
so yes i'm glad that she's learning from
her mistakes for sure but i can't
imagine a world in which she didn't
no and you know what i thought a really
great part of the episode was watch what
happens live with raquel with um james
and lala literally was like the breakup
episode
t was spilled every the whole episode
was like will lala and james date and
they both were like not into it but they
were like not out not into it they were
like
clawed like i think there's something
going on
to be honest i never in my life thought
that james was good looking like i never
understood how he pulled these girls but
when he was sitting in his apartment and
like the camera was like below him and
like his bones were like really chiseled
in his face i was like you know what
that is a handsome british man it's
until he opens his mouth that you're
like oh yeah and also like he's always
just come off as like this younger twerp
on the show like and it's just he
doesn't really seem like a
serious a serious guy so you don't look
at him in that way but i just watch what
happens live was so enjoyable first of
all like lala is
everything like first she looks so
amazing and she's really like she's not
holding back anything i mean she alludes
to like i still need to listen to all
the podcast episodes but unfortunately
there's no video so it's gonna like take
me a few months to get through
everything um
she alludes to like you know like these
dark disgusting things that like
happened in her relationship which i'm
not entirely sure
what that is and i don't think that that
stuff that she's even shared and there
is like a line because you know for
ocean like i'm sure she's not gonna put
a lot of stuff out there but she's
really like answering every question and
just being so
open she talked the talk and she's
walking the [ __ ] walk and i think
like for me what i was most impressed
with on watch ramen's live like she was
super open about everything with randall
but then she was also really open about
the fact that like the way that she got
together with randall when she looks
back on it now is like disgusting and
she's like
regretful and she like has you know
feelings about randall's ex-wife because
now that's her
and i just thought like
i don't know she talks a bit game on the
show like if this were me and i was
sheena but she's doing it like she
[ __ ] walked out she's done zero she
said her and randall communicate through
an app and it's only about ocean they
literally have not spoken since the day
she left like she's doing the damn thing
like you have to respect it i agree and
also i feel like she feels like she
can't speak on anything else because
like her situation is such a mess but
it's like
she has taken all of the advice that she
gave to sheena like i don't see her
people are like oh that didn't age well
like considerably i disagree i don't see
her as a hypocrite whatsoever i'm i
think she's someone who says one thing
and does the same thing and
she's even more justified now to judge
other people right but i feel like they
were asking her like some shady
questions and she just felt like funny
about even responding because it's like
you know what she's in no place who
judge she said but i just i don't think
that's really fair i feel like if she
had acted in a hypocritical way maybe
that's the case but like everything
she's done is everything she's told
sheena or anyone else to do
yeah so i think she needs to she needs
to be a little easier on herself
you know
and basically from james he was
basically like me and rachelle are
friends like there was nothing
interesting there yeah i'm excited for
the reunion though to see like they
although obviously i feel like they're
not really talking about james and
raquel's breakup because that's a lot of
the reunion stuff but it was really just
everyone i do think i think that there's
something going on between james and
lala because when they were asked the
question
it wasn't out of the realm of the
possibility like they were both like
kind of like laughing and like yeah you
never know which is like a crazy thing
to say about your best friend if that's
never gonna happen
and also
andy asks lala if she's dating yet
and she said i'm talking to some people
but i just don't feel right like taking
time away from ocean to go on a date
with someone but like with james she
doesn't have to do that so i feel like
right now like they could be like
hooking up i swear yeah but lala's
response which is 100 true like i don't
think james is ready to be a step dad
that's like a major right no i don't
think they're in a relationship at all
and i don't think they're going to be
but i think that they might be hooking
up yeah i would like that way
like it's not like she has to go out on
a date and you know whine and dine with
someone like james comes over they hang
out they have a good time and like maybe
they're hooking up you know an ocean's
just quietly sleeping in the next term
yeah and like j they're not like trying
to date or anything they're just like
trying to be there for each other 100 i
think it's very healthy i was really
surprised i would have thought that like
no never like they're just no they were
like and it was all virtual last name
but you could feel the chemistry between
the screens like i swear no i agree that
was a bummer that it was virtual because
i would have loved to see them in studio
together lala looked amazing
she looked amazing
so happy for her it was actually a
pretty good night of vanderpump rules
next week is the season finale and i'm
just so excited for james and raquel to
find out this moronic plan
same i'm glad lala's i'm sure lala will
be dragged
across the twitter sphere but it had to
be done that she is going to tell them
because it's wrong
it had to be done
also um there was like i mean so many
other things happen like the randall
meeting and the investing
i
like was annoyed at ariana for being
late but like [ __ ] happens and like the
way that everyone like days later was
dragging her at the winery it's like oh
my god i can't be late once like i
actually felt bad for her uh i don't
know it's not like she was like because
like she hit traffic and there was it
was totally out of her control like she
knew she had a meeting and then tom also
like tried to use serper with his notary
stuff and it's like that's true do it on
your own time i would have been really
[ __ ] pissed and i don't know what i
would have done if this was like a real
investor meeting if this was a real
investor meeting say like for you and i
toast whatever and my husband like
scheduled something that ultimately like
was for his stuff and like i had this
big meeting on the board like i would
leave i would say reschedule your notary
of course
so i noticed this episode so many
notaries wait and also i'm just getting
representation
so the sandwich shop is sounding better
and better agreed
i think
but also um
i thought charlie at the winery like she
was waiting like so
what no she was being so annoying like
drinking everyone's last drink being
like you [ __ ] it's like we're just
having dinner in san diego it's a
thursday night calm down the thing is
like they're just all on different pages
like charlie's giving very much season
one vanderpump rules and these are all
like married people with kids
and it's just not the vibe
no it's not the vibe at all and it's
like read the room and also like we have
a long weekend ahead of us i just
thought she was being like so annoying
how annoying is that person who like
every time you don't finish your drink
is like you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] like
okay that person is me so
no you're not you're real you're not
like if we were going on a weekend trip
to a winery and this seems to be
thursday night and it's gonna and i'm
already drunk
it's thursday night and it's gonna be a
long weekend like that's just like inch
welcome drinks and we're just whining
and dining like she was just being so
extra and it's like no that's not i'm
no it's it's not it was just like
you're on the wrong show
you're you're too late you're you're too
late
i'm sorry maybe you could go knock on
another door
i don't know why shows are out there i
agree
but it was just like
it was
it was not for me but i think people
like her yeah no she was growing on me
and i thought the episode honestly was
pretty good given like the off-camera
drama the watch weapons live i actually
am really looking forward to the season
finale which is like the first time i've
looked forward to literally anything
this season so it's all good
yeah no it's good it'll be interesting
to see where we go from here though like
with next season and because this season
i think overall
is it was like a transitional yes sir
time i can't imagine like it's gonna
stay the same for next year it's a
business show it's literally like shark
tank on bravo
i don't think this season really like
worked completely like overall that i
think they pulled it out and now the
stuff with like lala randall james and
raquel is like making it interesting but
um they're gonna have to change
something so i just wonder what it's
gonna be yeah
um
but that's our show
and somebody else's happy hump day
everyone tomorrow's episode is our last
of the week and it will be podcast only
so make sure you check that out thank
you so much for listening to the morning
toast millennium morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcast find out
some morning to us and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are and if you made it to the
end of this episode congratulations on
being a true toaster and a part of the
society season two to let us know that
you made it to the end of this episode
why don't you go drop an emoji on our
most recent instagram and make it the
fire emoji in honor of the
the flaming lava hot sauce sperm that
was sent of the instagram model's vagina
have an amazing day everyone we'll see
you tomorrow podcast only bye